welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
ufc prospect and wrestling phenom bone
nickel will be returning to the octagon
on september 27th on dana white's
contender series this will be nichol's
second appearance on the contender
series he submitted zachary borrego on
august 9th but surprisingly did not earn
a contract despite being called one of
the ufc's hottest prospects by dana
white nichols budding stardom has also
brought out quite a few doubters
appearing on michael bisping's believe
you me podcast ufc light heavyweight
anthony smith alluded that if nicol
really was an unstoppable wrestler he
would be doing other things right now
the reason beau nicol is in mma is
because he wasn't good enough to make an
olympic team the guys ahead of him in
the two weight classes he just can't
beat those two guys we're talking
olympic medalists world class some of
the best wrestlers to come out of
america or to ever step on a mat in the
world so i'm not discrediting him but he
can't beat those guys luke rockhold also
shared some thoughts on nickel during an
interview with the shmo when asked to
respond on nickel's comments that no one
at 185 could do 10 percent of what he
can do wrestling wise rockhold said bo
nickel would get abused absolutely
abused it's different wrestling is you
can only get so far until you run into
the likes of me rockhold did however try
to offer some praise to nickel calling
him a legit prospect but beau's a
credible character the kid looks good
but he fought a bum so who the [ __ ]
knows nickel responded to rock hold with
a comment on the show's instagram clip
of the exchange yo what why is this
clown even talking about me the likes of
me he says i'm dying however brendan
sharp did take the time to defend nicole
on the most recent episode of the shob
show saying that nichol's wrestling
pedigree is no joke i don't get the
kind of hate on beau nicholl as far as
you know his wrestling pedigree
now
was the olympic gold medalist no and did
he make the national team no you know
how hard is to be an olympic gold
medalist very few henry ceoudou there's
a not many man it's [ __ ] mission
impossible now you're talking about
one of the greatest collegiate wrestlers
ever
ever in bow nickel now the guy that he
lost to to get on the national team
which isn't in the weight class he
competes at but to get on the team
um you know he lost to david taylor who
i don't know if you know this went on to
win gold also was his training partner
for many of years so they know each
other david it's not like he lost a guy
who didn't make the team either he lost
to the guy so to
to go he's not even on the olympic team
i mean his wrestling's decent
decent wrestle bow nickel let me know
how it goes for you you're talking about
a he won the heisman for collegiate
wrestling
three-time all-american out of penn
state ever heard of it if i'm dana make
him the face contender series make him
the give make a container series
champion have bow nickel get experience
on the container series and guys have to
get through him to get to the ufc not a
bad test but also you got a superstar
bow nickel is the biggest prospect we've
had in
years if bow nickel is a stock i'm all
in and you're talking to a guy who
didn't touch crypto one championship
broke news of a major upcoming fight for
the one on prime video two cards slated
for september 30th adam weight champion
angela lee will challenge straw weight
champion zhang nan to try and earn
double chance status the bout will be
the pair's third with a record at one a
piece thick boy fight news had the
exclusive in-studio announcement with
lee we got some breaking news here now
you're at
uh the thick boy studios here it just so
happens
a little birdie told me you got a fight
announcement it's a big one it's one of
the amazon prime one championship cards
september 30th i think yep someone's
going down and what's the fight give it
to us all right guys so the trilogy
fight is happening i'm going up in
weight trying to capture that double
champ status gonna take the straw weight
belt zhang jing nan
champ champ now you beat her at adam
weight before and then she beat you
uh at the the upper weight so this is
the trilogy fight yeah it's going down
we're looking for a double champ well
he's double champ definitely
congrats thank you thank you thank you
let's go dominic cruz has issued his
first statement since his head kick
knockout loss to chito vera at ufc san
diego in a post to instagram cruz gave
an update about his health and said he
was eager to get back in a commentary
booth on september 10th for ufc 279
i'm grateful to all of you who came out
on saturday and for all the love and
support here the body feels great and
i'm thankful for my health i'll be
seeing you all next up on september 10th
at the desk hashtag team cruise henry
cejudo took to social media to break
down the cruise vera fight cejudo
offered much priest to cruise and finish
by saying he would like to see the
former champ continue fighting i was
actually impressed with dominic i had
gave the gave the game plan before you
really got to chop his legs if you
really want to beat him you won't catch
him here if you're too if you're too
straightforward if you're too stacked
like cheeto so what could i say dominic
did an amazing job of finding his rhythm
and getting cheeto off of his rhythm but
he would hear he would hear it
he would blitz into it or he would kick
he would he would kick and then jump
into the shot
inside boom
and he was throwing that's not my type
of forte it's not my style but whatever
man it is what it is uh where dominic
crews didn't do
right where he's fundamentally off is he
leans too much so typically so i'm
dominic i'm dominic cruz typically when
somebody yeah typically if dominic goes
to the left he's looking for take down
but when he goes to the right he's
looking to evade a punch or a kick the
problem is is cheeto did an amazing job
with cheetah with i'm cheeto now she did
an amazing job of peppering that jazz so
that should get dominant to lee
prepping that jack didn't dominate to me
to eventually catch him
and i thought she wrote he got on top of
him and uh
pretty much i saw she wrote my aftermath
what can i say about dominic i i thought
he looked good i don't think he should
retire i think there's the fight with
frankie edgar i think there's jose aldo
i think there's a legendary fight so
dominic i thought you looked i thought
you looked good i thought you were
winning the fight so i wouldn't retire
man as much as i don't compliment you i
think there's still a lot in speaking of
ufc 279 in a recent discussion with the
mack life welterweight hamza chemayev
spoke about his upcoming main event bout
with nate diaz when asked if he was
surprised that nate took the fight
chemiev didn't hold back yeah of course
because like himself he tells the
interviews bad matchup for him you know
like i can smash that guy easy the guy
is getting older he's not that guy who
beat mcgregor he's not that young guy
this is his last fight he's gonna lose
his fight and go some boxing i'll kill
him you know and kick him out let him go
chemief did however share that he does
respect diaz and his storied career when
i was a kid young boy i looked up to
that guy it's nice to see them in the
cage as well with me like somebody who
you looked up to he's a warrior nobody
can take from him he comes to fight
until the last second like he said
always kill or to be killed he's doing
all the time respect for him to take the
fight it's a bad fight for him you have
to give him respect chemiev then went on
to make a bold claim that he's the
biggest star in the ufc now everyone
understands when i beat that guy money
fight is me only me you know everyone
was running for me because i'm a bad
fight for everyone now they know it's
money money fight is me conor's away
he's on some movie habib is out israel
doesn't make good fights nobody wanna
see that guy fight now only me make real
fights i think i'm already the biggest
star in the ufc nobody wanna see those
guys what israel did all respect for
that guy he defended his title
everything he doing good a good job i am
here for fight like ufc needs everybody
want to see you fighting not playing
making points like playing tennis you
know looking for more original mma
content check out the rest of thick boy
youtube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shop show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action